hello my name is Rodrigo obonda and I'm
here to present I would say a guided
tour of the elementary cellular automata
and beyond and this is about arranging
the behavior of the rules in the
elementary cellular automata in other
bigger spaces in a meaningful way in
terms of the behavior all right thank
you for coming I'm gonna be talking
about the elementary cellular automata
and I hope that that was I should have
actually put that in there I'm assuming
that everybody knows what ECA is but I'm
gonna talk about this under a context of
a paper that are published a couple of
years ago you know different way of
mapping the rules taking what I call
primitives and finding the dynamics of
the rules and then laying those out on
space and I'm gonna show that in let me
go here to the next so that's that's the
abstract this is actually published in
is going to be published in the
conference so they can read that at your
leisure
but essentially what happens is when
when we studied the the cellular
automata and we are interested in the
dynamic behavior of the rules we find it
that there was at least it was not a
visible how the different behavior was
related to the actual rule because the
rule indicates local behavior not global
behavior in ascend any complex systems
trying to draw some information about
the global behavior given that the local
behavior is it's sort of difficult you
know the the fact that we know what
happens at the local the local part of
the or the rule that doesn't mean that
I'm gonna know what happens in the
global so the majority of times that
we've actually lay out all the rules and
the behaviors is just you know for
instance for the elementary center
automata which there are 256 rules it
goes from 0 to 255 and when you see the
revolution of those
going from one to another it doesn't
really tell you much it just simply
shows different evolutions but they
don't they don't come together they you
know you don't see any rhyme and reason
why they are that way so we normally
assume that they are just randomly
distributed but when I looked at this
and this work for some time for this I
realized that maybe we were looking at
the rules in a little bit different way
for instance back when Langton I think
was back in the 80s it started to say
well we can compute the lambda of of our
rules by the number of ones that we have
in the rule and what was assuming that
every single one that you have in the
rule will be you know will be producing
dynamic behavior but in reality is not
because some of those rules some of
those mappings are saying okay when you
have your central cell equal to one and
then your output is gonna be one there
is no change so there is no dynamic
behavior so I looked at it differently
and say okay let's partition this in
three minutes and then we have the
primitive zero which means whenever that
is zero and it's actually going to go to
one thus dynamic is going to introduce
change in whenever if the the primitive
one is that the central cell is one and
is going to be zero that's dynamic
that's going to introduce this so now I
look at all the rules in in the
elementary automata and two or four is
for instance the identity the identity
is zero change that means whatever comes
into them to the rule it is just exactly
what it comes out and 51 is completely
the opposite because 51 is the
complement so whatever I have as a zero
it goes to a 1 whatever have is R 1 it
goes to zero so so this way we go from
completely inert
nothing changes to completely
changing and we have everything in
between we have in fact 256 but what
happens with this is that when we order
this and there there was no way you know
sort of ordered ID and this is for the
battle for some time for some time ago
and I have issues with that they say how
do i order this because every time that
I'm at this it will always go to maybe a
two dimensional view and it never never
satisfied what I was looking for so what
I did is I looked at those and I realize
that perhaps they are not perfectly
ordered but they are partially ordered
and here's I have the partial order
primitives and then there are actually
16 primitives per pranaam you know 16
primitives and every rule has two
primitives so this 16 by 16 me gives a
256 and then I can order all this in a
lattice in this lattice as you can see
no so it's a partial order and then by
showing it this way I can then navigate
from one to another but I do that now
for primitive 1 a primitive zero I'm
primitive one that is gives me 256 and
then I order this this way
so I created then a simple view of that
so that I could display the 256
unfortunately it's very very little we
cannot really see that I wish I could
just go over to the the screen and show
you that but then for instance if I go
back in here I do have a tooltip that
actually magnifies that entry evaluates
so that's 2 or 4
that's identity and that actually has a
single one as the input now if I go all
the way over here that is 51 which is
now we have everything in between you
can see this the interesting thing is
for instance the sierpinski rules you
know the ones that reduce the sierpinski
triangle you know I actually found them
whole you know hanging out over here
they're all together no other depiction
of the whole rules are actually having
all those together I mean they are all
exactly the same for a single so a
single one so they're all around here so
it means that this way of showing the
rules is actually showing clusters or
groups of rules that have similar
behavior now there was something
interesting when I see I saw this I
realized that if you do the complement
the complement will be this rules
completely you know where are they I
think there are around here like that
one that one is a complement of one of
those rules but now what are the other
ones you know I had to go and find him
but if I flip that and then I say go
ahead and flip how am ordering now we'll
know explain it momentarily
how this is ordered I mean you're all
the way this
when I flip this first of all this group
over here they all had primitive zero
they were all the same now they are all
the same with primitive primitive one so
I flipped it now this is all of this at
the same primitive one and each one of
those of variation of primitive two so
it happens that now I find the
complement rules in the same place the
interesting thing is and this is what
what is deceiving there was deceiving to
me and I said when I looked at a table
with all the evolution for a single one
and I looked at that and said hmm that
is not the one that I was looking for I
was looking for another just like this
one but it's not there why so I realized
that just the same way that I'm using
the complements that you also have to
reverse your input when you reverse your
input now they will behave the same way
that the complements will behave with a
single one on a way for a moment here
I wish I didn't have to compute so much
but if each one of the rules is being
computed by you know twice one for the
small and L for the big one because it's
a tooltip so now I come back and you can
see all the sierpinski complement
together just just like the other one
right over here so they're all here
together in the same group so this way
of putting the rules together that
actually shows you that there is some
sort of structure in the space that I
can actually look at so here let me see
this is rule 30 and rule 86 should be
around here there you go
that 86 not 35
there's an 86 so if you explore this and
this is a it's gonna be available
you know poll showed you can actually
explore this you realize that there are
a lot of things that are you know all
sort of behaving similar I had to flip
it account again so does it show this so
one of the first things that I did the
other things that the reason for the
beyond and the title is because one of
the problems that we have with the
bigger spaces is if we want to explore
that four billion rules which will be
the general the next step you know we
have 256 here we can put them in here
even for this we realize that it's a lot
of computation so I don't even want to
think about and I don't think that
anybody has really explored the four
billion rules of the of the next you
know for the foot range to so but this
way of ordering the rules it happens and
I didn't put this in here every rule is
joined to another rule to the left and
to the right and they are the difference
between them is one bit so there is only
one bit of difference in between them so
when we take those two rules you know
let's say this one or this one over here
to this one over here if you take those
two rules and you say okay let's take
this two and now map these two rules to
the next space so they go from the 256
to the four billion rule so they are
distilled the same rules but now I can
have variations in between them and in
fact it gives me 256 in total so I can
expand this it's like using a magnifying
glass and say I want to go inside this
to see what is how is it that for
instance a particular rule over here
changes to this other rule and since I'm
not showing the the connection between
the rules so I have another
another little thing in here that
actually allows me to do that so I think
it's 236 this one actually writes which
are the neighboring the immediate
neighbors so 236 for instance connects
to 110 let me expand this a little bit
so this is your class 4 and 1/10 so it's
connected to 236 so what happens between
a single line over here that actually
becomes 110 and that's what I have the
next slide is the one that shows that
here I can I can then say I want to go
over on and then this is 236 to 110 so
this is now expanding from 236 to 110 so
all the variations in between the two
you know this actually gives me 256
forget because for every every bit of
difference there are two there are a
total of four bits of difference so
that's a bits difference so that gives
me 256 and as you can see it it starts
right over here this is the mapped rule
to 36 but this is mapped to the bigger
space that goes all the way to 110 and
I'll see how interesting all this over
here everywhere on this side it's just
like the first one and suddenly they
start changing and we go the the
depiction of this is from no activity to
more activity or more dynamics so in
here I started looking at this and I
said well this is very interesting look
at all the kinds of rules some of them
are similar and a look at that if you
recognize 110 that's 110 mapped to the
bigger space
and then I discover something like this
and I said wait a minute that looks like
one time but it looks like I didn't run
it for enough steps and I believe there
is another place that that is
so here
no I think it that was it so I looked at
that and I thought I went and made a
mistake you know this one so I thought
of what it was I have made a mistake if
you see has the same the same kind of
evolution no going down that I
recognized from 1:10 you know you go
look up a 1 10 and said hey that's 110
but I'm running it for a thousand steps
right here so if I look at that now in
at half of it it shows this one and I
saw what's intrigued that was
immediately what what happened with this
and then I went ahead and I said okay
let me collect this in fact I went in
and and did other explorations in other
group was 256 and I found a total of 4
they do exactly the same so I took those
and I call them High Definition
evolution of rule 110 single input so
these are the ones that I collected also
that they were similar but this one over
here this is 1 10 projected to the row
to the radius 2 so this 4 over here if
you see those carefully you'll see for
instance this pixel over here it's
actually reproduced in exchange for a
triangle and with another two pixels
over here this one over here is created
a bigger triangle you know higher
definition triangle you know see the
staircase over here
it's a lot finer in here so all I had to
do to be able to show that was to
make it oops that's not what I meant
I want it to be
now he's running no don't do that
yeah
I need to do it
I thought I had done it thank you okay
there we go
100
so here we go so they are identical
except that it is high resolution so if
I go to you know five
so it has the same behavior and I think
if I don't go to radios 3 it will be
exactly the same but even finer detail
so but just by looking at something like
this I sort of discovered this and I
haven't seen anything like this which is
the same behavior of 110 but at a higher
resolution it's something is it my
question is is it that the 110 behavior
is something Oh be curious in many other
places and we will find it at a higher
risk of the resolution I still don't
know yes I'd mean is if you if you see
the 110 the 110 do you see the jaggies
you know that are formed right in here
when you when you look at this this the
yeah is less prominent so if you look at
it from far away this looked more like a
straight line than that one
yes but if if I just double the number
of steps now they are I can impose one
on top of another and they have the same
place where you have the same triangles
the same you know all the way to however
many I have and I didn't have to do
anything except to run it twice and it's
a different rule so if I do 100
or 300
if you go you know nice too much if you
go very close to that you know they look
the same except when you look closer it
is like a higher resolution let me go
into the next one
because I already run out of time the
next one is you see the same way so they
do coarser you know in in computer
graphics we we call that that in this
case that 110 is the MIT map of the
other one so I found those those that
have that general behavior except that
there are the high resolution my
triangles are better defined etc if I go
to radius 3 I'm sure that I'm going to
find the same kind of behavior but in
such a way that if I continue doing that
I will be able to see a fine line
instead of just even seeing the
staircase and I'll be able to see that
it's true that I have to use more steps
but at the same time it's doing exactly
the same thing as rule 110 so 110 is
like a blurred version of this pattern
you know all the way to 1 to the EC a
which is 4 I remember that Stephen said
eca you know is the first is the the the
lowest level where we find something
interesting like +4 so that's one of the
things that I found and and I just
wanted to show something like that I I
need to explain beste gate and look at
the form of the rules to see if I can
identify why you know how is it that
they are related so that the these other
rules are actually reproduced in this
pattern and I want to see if this is a
general rule for instance if I look into
rule 30 will I find a higher definition
of rule 30 in
in you know and and radius to and
continue for this the other thing is
that this method I cannot and I don't
have it but I should be able to go from
the radius to and say take two of those
that are also neighboring and then open
it up go to radius three and see another
256 so starting with the ECA I can go
deeper into the general set of rural
spaces injustice aside I do have a
visualization of this using the hololens
unfortunately is not with Mathematica
yet because I'm working you know
participating in the beta unity link
which actually is going on right now
with Charles Pugh we're trying to do
that a link between Unity game engine
and Mathematica but I do have a version
of of this in three dimensions so I can
I can walk around it and look at the
different things in the space
unfortunately is implemented in c-sharp
and so it is it's not a Mathematica I
wish I had it but if any of you have
interested of I have the whole Alliance
not here with me but have it around have
it in my room and I would like to to
show you and that's about it
all right
drill
yes
don't have note that I know that you
mentioned that one
right
yes yes and that's the idea you see the
the the first scene that I wanted to do
was to organize this to see like like
this one
I I don't think I would have ever found
something like that just by randomly
going into the four billion rule space
so by looking at that I want to see then
how I said that the primitives are
expressing the rules you know and then
formalize it but yes yeah that's that
I've been looking at all kinds of papers
like that and you know some do a certain
ways and some other ways and but they
don't necessarily map this the space
like I've been trying to do
just you know I know it's that's you
know I mean trying to go to radio streak
which is you know to 3128
so it's quite a bit
I has student well he graduated and he
was actually looking a year ago I
presented a problem probabilistic DCI
and he was doing something like that to
find but the the way that we were doing
is finding it in the neighbors and we
found something like that like you saw
the sierpinski they're all together
so we could actually find them very
quickly but I'm thinking that what
Steven was showing yesterday could be
used for something like that when I saw
it I said yes because I could use it
with images and then look for this kinds
of patterns all right
c-sharp
know what I do have our cubes that have
the images the cellular automata output
on top of it and then I have it in three
dimensions order in this lattice but
it's I have the three dimensions sister
of just having it flat so it is easier
for me to navigate and look around yeah
all right
thank you thank you appreciate it